Je joue mes 3 dernières dates de spectacle en décembre 2016 au Zénith de Pariiiiiiis
Venez.
Avec l'été qui arrive, il  y a plein de gens qui se mettent à la musculation
Moi aussi j'ai essayé
et en quelques mois, franchement, on commence à voir les résultats
FAUX !
Alors histoire vraie, la 1ère fois que je suis allé à la salle,
j'ai fait du vélo elliptique,
et là le gérant de la salle est arrivé pour présenter la salle à un couple.
Et il y a eu ce moment gênant :
Donc là-bas on a la partie musculation
pour les hommes bien virils
Et puis ici on a les vélos elliptiques
pour les femmes
C'est bien ça
C'est bien pour les femmes
C'est un ....
Une belle machine !
Oui je sais
Le vélo elliptique c'est pas forcément QUE pour les femmes
Mais bon. J'ai quand même arrêté d'en faire.
Alors, j'ai aussi essayé de courir sur un tapis
Sauf que moi, au bout de 25 secondes
Bah qu'est ce qui se passe ?
J'ai un point de côté.
Déjà au collège, j'me rappelle quand on courrait
j'étais le premier à avoir un putain de point de côté
ATTENDEZ !
J'ai un point de côté là
Pfouuuuuuuuuuuuu
Contrôle.
J'ai vu à la salle de sport qu'il y avait aussi une liste de différents cours collectifs
Je peux comprendre qu'il y aie des gens qui kiffent
Par contre j'ai pas compris le principe du cours collectif de vélo.
Là faut m'expliquer
*coup de sifflet*
Bon allez vos gueules !
Bonjour à tous
Alors le vélo, très simple
Au début, vous vous posez dessus comme ça
vous pédalez en avant
et puis c'est tout
Voilà, bon courage à tous !
Ah merde ! Ah c'est... D'accord !
Vers l'avant !
J'avais pas...
J'avais pas compris
A la salle, quand je vois un mec musclé faire de la muscu
j'ai trop envie de lui dire
Euh c'est bon t'es assez musclé là
Tu peux t'arrêter maintenant j'crois
Moi en muscu, le poids que je soulève
c'est vraiment le poids le plus petit possible.
J'me sens toujours ridicule
surtout quand je passe après un mec qui a soulevé
200 000 kilos
Ben dis donc. Pas mal pour un débutant
Merci
*Bruit de honte*
Les habitués à la salle de muscu
j'te jure, quand ils poussent fort,
ils lâchent des cris. Phouaaaaah !!!!
Phouuuu !!!
Attends c'est hyper gênant
Toi t'es sur la machine d'à côté,
t'as pas forcément la même perception
*cris virils sur fond de musique sensuelle*
Ça me dérange pas hein
*ooooh*
Au contraire, c'est un vrai plaisir
*oh ouiiii*
Huit
Tout le monde vous le dira
à la muscu, y a toujours un mec
qui vient te donner des conseils sur comment te muscler
alors que lui
ah bah il est pas musclé du tout, en fait
C'est au moment où tu pousses qu'il faut bien contracter le muscle pour developper la masse, tu vois ?
Cooooomme ça, voilà
- Apparemment, ça a pas trop trop marché sur toi hein ? *Autre bruit de honte*
Peut-être qu'on devrait...
2,3,4 !
*aaaaaah*
Alors attention, y a pas que des relous à la salle
Tu rencontres aussi plein de gens cools
qui te donnent des vrais conseils
Moi on m'a conseillé
et grâce à des mecs, maintenant j'y arrive mieux.
Décidément, vraiment pas mal hein !
Merci !
Tu lâches la barre steuplait ?
Merci.
Mais la grosse difficulté en muscu je trouve
c'est vraiment la motivation et la régularité
T'sais quand tu commences, t'es vraiment un gros gamin
T'as envie que les résultats viennent super vite
J'suis désolé, ça fait 6 mois que je suis inscrit et j'ai toujours aucun muscle.
Ça marche pas.
- Ah bah faut peut être venir à la salle, monsieur !
Ah faut...Faut venir ?
Bah du coup j'vais faire une séance hein
Ok, eh bah pour vous j'ai une formule spéciale "corps de lâche"
Le mardi.
A la salle de sport, le coach me disait que
y a beaucoup de gens qui prennent un abonnement à l'année
et qui ne viennent jamais.
Alors moi je me disais peut-être qu'il y aurait un business à monter
Bonjour. Moi c'est Philippe
Avant j'étais au chômage mais j'étais quand même inscrit à la salle de sport.
Et comme tous mes amis, j'y allais jamais
Du coup, j'ai eu une petite idée.
J'ai monté ma propre boîte.
Muscu 3000
La première salle du sport sans aucune machine.
Voilà maintenant un an que Philippe a monté sa salle de sport
Il a déjà près de 500 clients qui paient mais ne viennent pas
Du coup, pas besoin de matériel.
Philippe est content.
Il s'fait juste un peu chier
Mais vous avez pas peur qu'un jour un adhérent arrive ?
Ça risque pas, c'est pas le concept.
- Bonjour !
Ah! Il y a pas de machines ?
Euh... non il y a pas de machine mais ...
Bah vous pouvez faire des pompes par terre là si vous voulez
Muscu 3000 ! Inscrivez-vous, il y a de tout !
Y a pompes, abdos au sol, tout !
Cinq, six, sept, la PUISSANCE là, ALLEZ!
Suite au reportage et à plusieurs plaintes,
Philippe Harnak a fermé Muscu 3000 et s'est désormais reconverti
dans le monde de la merguez
Alors les mecs qui inventent les exercices à la salle :
Parfois c'est des pros. Et c'est crédible.
Et parfois c'est pas des pros.
Et c'est pas crédible.
En tout cas, j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les gens qui font la musculation
ou du sport en général
Alors, je vous encourage vraiment à continuer
Moi j'ai kiffé cette expérience et j'espère que vous appréciez mon petit récit
Et puis de toute façon,
le plus important, c'est d'aimer son corps tel qu'il est
de sentir en harmonie avec
et d'être heureux, tu vois ?
Moi je me sens bien comme ça.
Et alors ? T'as un problème ? Tu veux qu'on se tape?
Bah non, on ne va pas se taper. Pourquoi ?
Parce que j'ai aucune force.
Alors n'hésitez pas de mettre un petit pouce en air bien musclé viril si vous avez aimé
et  on se revoit très bientôt pour l'amour de love
Ciao!